you
all right welcome everybody what a day
what a day it is early
we are on the precipice here of an
historic day
uh the blue origin new shepherd of
course of jeff
bezos fame and we will talk about that
is just moments from seeing the four
astronaut crew um
loaded into the new shepherd this is all
happening live
it's only 8 20 a.m on the east coast
5 20 a.m on the west coast and
a completely reasonable time of the
early afternoon if you're in europe i
mean there's just nothing notable about
the time if you're in europe it's a
perfect time to be watching
a live stream so welcome everybody we
are 43 minutes from the scheduled launch
as we see
the rivian electric vehicle wow look at
the product placement
um moving the four astronauts now the
the four people that are going up are
jeff bezos his brother uh this 82 year
old
woman known for being one of the first
female not only
commercial pilots but also fl of pilot
instructors flight instructors
and then notably um some rich anonymous
person
donated 30 million to get that fourth
seat and then i guess had a scheduling
conflict so some kids going i mean
can you imagine uh but a really really
exciting uh
day and um many many millions of people
expected to watch
so it is great to be here now different
than
the launch of the richard branson virgin
galactic craft just what feels like
about 10 days ago
this new shepherd is a vertical takeoff
um craft remember with
the branson vehicle it was essentially a
rocket
small craft that was taken up
on a bigger airplane that was a a
horizontal takeoff this is a completely
different thing
the branson craft also had pilots
whereas this is all
automated um so it is uh it is really
really quite a day
and um i don't even know what to say
other than
jeff bezos we are sending him up into
the air sir your wife is up in the air
exactly and um it's just there's just a
lot going on so
i will be here we will be here we are 40
minutes away we're taking super chats
we will chat with people uh i i'll i
have other things that i'm going to go
over
and different elements i have a couple i
mean we'll i have some normal stream
type things that we
that we can do and go over uh but really
the big thing here oh and why are we at
29
also why not we will even open phone
lines
on this historic day if we get to 100
website members and twitch subscribers
i mean i know it's early it's a weird
time but we are going to uh we are going
to do it all
i do want to say thank you to the
wilhelm screen as well as the winter
crow
for the twitch prime subscriptions very
much appreciate that in kicking us off
let's just listen briefly here to what
is being discussed
you are a pilot i don't want you to go
fly more in that glider and then
and jumping oh that's great and
hopefully follow in your footsteps and
go on new shepard one day
absolutely i mean so wally you've you've
waited a while to go to space
um silly question but are you excited
no not at all
of course all right so doing some
pre-recorded cringe content as you see
the live shot
in the lower right that is the crew uh
getting over
to the uh yeah we'll mute for now we'll
mute for now i understand i understand
what's going on
let me um adjudicate just
one unban request we do these
sporadically a user named cole
birmingham
invaded the chat just uh some period of
time ago
came in and said joe biden is the
equivalent of a house plant
then they said xenophobic are you an
effing idiot they were banned
their unban request is unban me [ __ ]
and that is going to be denied and made
permanent
i don't have my gavel with me because
it's so early in the morning
so one unbanned request and a very very
easy one
to adjudicate for me we are
because we are sending jeff bezos up in
the air
we actually have a very special one-day
coupon code at joinpakman.com the code
is
up in the air all one word all lower
case sir your wife is up in the air
exactly and you can take advantage of
that at joinpackman.com
we also will be um i will read super
chats if people send them in
i will uh we we will go over a number of
different things
i've been asked just to see uh because
i'm often
referred to as a uh boomer
um i've been asked to take the gen z
slang quiz so i'm just gonna do this
real quick as we wait
and see uh how i will do on this am i
still cool okay
what does no cap mean that means no lie
or for real
got it right beautiful all right let's
see if i can hang with the jen's ears
what about suss abbreviation of
suspicious or suspect that's easy
uh what does bop mean again
bop it's not a type of insect it's not a
sport i think it's something that's
vintage in a cool way oh no i got it
wrong oh my god bop is a really good
song
maybe i am an idiot when something
slaps what does it mean that's an
expression of how good something is
got it what does it mean when someone
says
facts i think that just means truth
okay very good what does it mean if
someone
says go off oh that's an encouragement
to keep going with what they're saying
nice if someone responds mood
to something you say what does that mean
i think it means like they share the
mood meaning same here
nice lastly what does the vibes are
immaculate mean
i think that means that the vibes are
good beautiful all right
so i guess my gen z vibes are immaculate
that's good all right so we got that out
of the way
and please no more boomer allegations as
that
uh quiz has has made it clear that
that's not the case
dennis says via super chat sir what's
the most amount of money you would pay
to go to space
you know right now i i don't want right
now i don't want to go in other words i
want to let the technology develop
before i i go so right now nothing i
guess depending on how the technology
develops
my answer would change in the future we
are watching the crew
now enter the blue origin new
shepard craft remember that this is a
vertical takeoff craft
the plan is that they will be going um
up into the air
as they say and experiencing zero
gravity i believe going to an elevation
of about a hundred miles
the richard branson virgin galactic
craft
from about 10 days ago went i believe it
was to the 65 mile 279
000 feet how many miles is that
i'll just look at the calculator um
279 divided by 5280. oh 52 miles okay so
the branson craft went about 52 miles
up i believe this is a going going close
to
close to 100 miles up and as you can see
uh the
the astronauts there
very very close to loading in and we are
36 minutes
from the scheduled takeoff so far the
weather seems uh appropriate
and they are going forward with uh with
the entire thing which is very exciting
i do have a couple of um voicemails just
to oh sorry
i want to say thanks to mighty core for
subscribing via twitch prime
as well as james lean new members three
and four today
we will do early morning um phone calls
if indeed we get to 100. let's listen in
a little bit the world's most brilliant
engineers flying this rocket today and i
don't know about you but i'm starting to
get a little bit emotional
um so back to you ariana and we'll see
it we'll see after launch
thank you caitlin enjoy the launch jared
jones enjoy the launch everybody out
there
outside of mission control as well as in
mission control enjoy the launch
you know gary we talked about it a
little bit earlier
okay so down to 35 minutes 35 minutes
i have a couple of voicemails i'm going
to play for you guys
these are hand selected let's listen
to the first one hi david can you please
show us your eggplant on only fans
um okay
and then um here is another one
beta male
girly man
[Music]
okay not exactly
the uh height of
you know conversation
yeah so there it is that's that's a
caller
making a comment if you can imagine
um not not too much else
to say about that really i don't know if
it's supposed to be funny
i don't know if it's supposed to be like
a big attack on me or if it's supposed
to be a joke or
i genuinely don't know i genuinely don't
know
okay we are very close to the half
hour mark the um
astronauts and by that i mean jeff bezos
and his brother
an 82 year old pilot and flight
instructor
and an 18 year old kid have been
loaded into the capsule at the top of
the
of the rocket up here
and down to just about 33 minutes until
this gets going as we get closer and
closer we'll switch over
from the standpoint of audio to so that
we can listen to mission control and
and the entire thing but in the meantime
i will continue to to hear from you guys
now there i i'm getting a little bit of
a weird vibe that there are people
that almost like they want this to crash
they want these four people to die
that's weird to me you know i mean
saying you think it's a problem that at
this point
this experience is
limited to the ultra rich that's a fair
you know criticism um talking about
you know the carbon emissions or
whatever but like hoping that these
people die
you know like don't hope that jeff bezos
dies if you want to send a message just
take your five bezo bucks on twitch and
subscribe to my channel like we don't
need to hope people die that seems very
strange to me
this is the pre-loading area here as you
can see
[Music]
i would be quite nervous if i were them
i would be very very nervous if i were
them i will uh
i will be very upfront about that but
they seem relaxed unclear if
benzodiazepines are a factor here and
i have no reason to believe that they
are it's merely a question
that i'm asking um this is
uh remember the the new shepherd that we
will be seeing
launch in about 32 minutes is a vertical
takeoff and vertical landing
launch vehicle that's the that's the
rocket piece
you then have the tip as it's being
called which is the capsule
and a development of this engine type
and vehicle started in 2006
and um full-scale engine development
started about 10 11 years ago was
completed in 2015
they they've been doing significant
uncrewed flight testing
and um that's been going on for six
years and the new the big
thing is this will be the first crude uh
that's that's not c-r-u-d-e but
c-r-e-w-e-d
flight and that is going to be just a
half hour from now
now they are getting ready to cross over
let's take a listen
there's jeff bezos the richest man in
the world that's his brother
what a moment jeff bezos
mark bezos
wally funk
and oliver damon ring the ceremonial
bell
making some noise on their way to get
into the crew capsule
i wish they had a less cringy sort of
anchor i'm with you guys
is now going to help them ingress get
into the capsule
get situated in their seats and uh
of course help them get buckled into
their harnesses and go through any
final safety checks before closing the
hatch i mean
we should note though gary and i again i
have both been through the
astronaut training experience it's a
five-point harness by the by the time
you're done with training
you can do that upside down backwards
with your eyes closed
uh inside and out i mean you you
definitely understand how
all right so just moments away from the
crew entering the craft
um it is quite a day quite a day if
you're just joining us scheduled for 9
00 a.m
eastern time and based on the countdown
still 30 minutes away looks like it's
gonna be more like 904
eastern 604 a.m pacific time
um and uh three in the afternoon
in spain in case anybody from spain is
joining us today
this is expected to be an 11-minute
flight
um based on the last that i read unless
that has been changed
and um the individual who purchased the
fourth seat for 28 million dollars
uh unable to attend so there is an
18 year old oliver damon who instead is
taking that
fourth seat um
can you imagine 28 million bucks but has
has a scheduling conflict
so entering the cabin they will be
getting strapped in
jonathan mccartney just came in with a 5
000 yen super chat i have no idea how
much that is in us dollars it must be
like a million us dollars
hypothetical for you says jonathan
assuming the communist ideal the
elimination of private capital could be
achieved and sustained at some point in
the future would you support it
or do you believe that cap private
capital is sacrosanct
i don't believe private capital is
sacrosanct
but i am not a communist and i would not
be supportive
of eliminating private capital i'm i'm
just you know
there will be people who will say david
sir how could you do
it's you're a traitor no i'm a social
democrat that's a well-regulated form of
capitalism so i would not uh
i would not be in favor of that i do
want to remind people if you're just
joining us because we are
celebrating that they are sending jeff
bezos
up into the air sir your wife is up in
the air
we do have a coupon code at
joinpakman.com that code is
up in the air it's an ungodly discount
it's
un unearthly it's it's an it's a
discount that
uh wants to escape the
harness of gravity and so i can't even
tell you how big of a discount it is but
it will work at jointpakman.com it's an
out of this world discount exactly
that's the right way to say it
um let's see someone called me a libtard
but within about half a second they were
blocked which is a really really nice
action taken by one of our moderators
that's very very quick and people are
really doing a good job really really
doing a good job
um all right and
we are now down to the last 27 minutes
here let's take a listen
i can see it's jammed in there don't
don't keep pulling on it
sounds like audio from the capsule
so again we've got capcom sarah knight
she's one of our crew member seven on
the left our four astronauts are loaded
into the capsule
there is wally
as well as mission control talk about
how about locked and loaded this team
is really i mean you've been in emission
control
during during these launches what is
that like
so at this point in the procedure
everybody is incredibly focused they're
true professionals
they are they are looking at the data i
mean i don't i don't know if jeff bezos
is exactly a
space flight professional but at least
he's going up there i do want to say
thank you to small
fuzzy moss as well as guitar
goddess for the twitch subs numbers five
and
six today uh we are more than willing to
open phone lines
after the launch if uh we fill up this
bar to 100 which can be done one of two
ways
either with a twitch subscription use
those bezos bucks
or by signing up at joinpakman.com we
have a one day coupon code for today
called up in the air sir your wife is up
in the air
plastic pinocchio sends the super chat
i'd like to
also to point out that 100 years ago
commercial air travel was just as
expensive and experimental
i'm sure in another hundred years
everyone will be able to go to orbit and
maybe even farther
yeah i don't you know for me it's not a
great
argument that the cost per person for
this
is really high and you could like you
know
end hunger with it that's always been an
argument that was an argument with
commercial
um uh airliners that was an argument
with the first cars i mean look at look
at what the first cars cost
relative to incomes at the time and it's
like hey look you could have fed
a uh town for that um
you know at the per capita costs for all
of these things
are significant and
we don't even know the degree to which
this type of development
will um uh bring
dividends pay dividends in the future so
for me that's not like a great
argument um i think
more the arguments that there's an
there's such an ungodly level of wealth
that is held by just a few people
that they don't even they're like out of
stuff to spend money on
and it's a taxation issue certainly with
amazon
you know it's a capturing of profit
issue those are really good
big meaty thick arguments
uh but just like the per capita of
sending someone to space right now is
too high
uh that's the case with just about
anything that that that is
you know pushing the bounds of
technology there are some people saying
well this
there's not really new technology here
okay but the these
uh we're we're moving in a direction
when it comes to commercial space flight
that is new um bay photo says woke up
early pacific time to watch another
billionaire launch themselves into space
hope it's worth it
oh um ahri bawayau says you have at
least one person from spain watching are
you coming on
vacation yes i will be up in the air
and going to spain very soon sir your
wife is up in the air
um delta fears rising a little bit but
government needs you to bring your
acquired
twitch bezos bucks i'm going to be
bringing bezos bucks to spain absolutely
i want to say thank you to marcy mike
for the twitch sub you were number seven
today
number seven we also have as
uh as of yet not taken advantage of we
have a special
coupon code just for today that code is
up in the air
all one word all lowercase
uh because of sending people up into the
air
and oh it looks like we've had our first
person take advantage of it
matthew denman just signed up on my
website with the coupon code
up in the air sir your wife is up in the
air exactly
exactly thank you matt i very much
appreciate that
matthew burr says deepak giga-based like
always hey by the way i don't know if
people saw this
but on reddit's
there were a whole bunch of posts about
my commentary let me see if i can find
this
um my commentary about hassan's
commentary
about uh uh stephen kenneth destiny
bennell's commentary like look at this
where was it people were com people came
to me and they said sir we found you on
popular in reddit people who you know i
haven't spoken to for a while
let's see where were these uh yeah look
at this
1600 comments david pakman blown away
by hassan's rant about destiny this was
just one of them and there were a whole
bunch of other really really strong ones
doing destiny content and be like oh my
god i'm so offended that people are
using the term gusano
a term that most people had to [ __ ]
google immediately after i [ __ ]
mentioned it for the first time ever
and it's actually certainly not
political uh and and uh
can only be used against cubans and uh
it's not just
a catch-all [ __ ] term that a lot of
leftist latin americans use
against people that they perceive to be
like capitalist anti-imperialist
counter-revolutionaries um you know
i'm so offended i'm so offended what
this dude literally just uses social
justice
and people of color as a [ __ ] prop
just to like
be like i'm so offended on behalf of
everyone else he's
no different than he's like he's the
edgy
what sjw is [ __ ] blue hair okay
that's all he is
he literally just weaponizes social
justice when it's appropriate
and then writes a [ __ ] manifesto okay
so that did re that that
did surprisingly well on reddit i
actually did exchange
some messages with hassan the morning
after and i was like i do think it's a
slur but
this is not like the biggest issue for
me and i you know you're welcome on any
time and like we had a perfectly fine
uh conversation the next day um i do
want to say thank you to spencer sansom
who just
signed up with the coupon code up in the
air
sir your wife is up in the air also want
to say thank you to chris fantana
taking advantage about the coupon code
sir your wife is up in the air
there we go and those are new members
number nine and 10 today
and because we are going up into the air
with jeff bezos and others
the uh coupon code available today other
super chats going on
um can you give me an understanding of
an index fund and how
etfs work in them how etfs work
in them i don't even understand you
could have an etf you can have an index
fund index fund
is essentially a fund that is indexed
to something else so if you have a s if
you have an s p 500 index fund
it's indexed to the s p 500 if the s p
goes up a one percent then your fund
goes up one percent you're not picking
individual stock it just
tracks the uh
index it's a fund based on an index
for 28 million dollars what couldn't be
rescheduled yeah that's a fair question
it's a fair question um
hi david watching from japan it's 9 41
pm here
great to have you kyoko kyoko has
actually called into the show before
the the author of some perfect phone
calls
joel says don't care much for bezos
going to space but wally funk's story is
very cool glad she's getting this
opportunity
absolutely very interesting story wally
funk was
not only one of the sort of pioneer
female pilots
at a time when it was really rare even
more rare than now
also as a flight instructor very
interesting story
i want to say thanks to nightmare 99 as
well as darth bane for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 11
and 12 today sager
says thoughts on hyperloop is it a good
idea for the biden administration to
invest in the technology as richard
branson has said
i am into the idea of the biden
administration
investing into all sorts of uh
rapid transit technology it doesn't have
to be
hyperloop there's people who say
hyperloop isn't uh cost effective for a
variety of reasons
i am agnostic on hyperloop i am very
much
strong on uh that type of
that type of development yeah it's not
even rapid transit that's true it's not
even the right term
felix firod says come on jeffrey you can
do it pave the way put your back into it
uh yeah okay very good ronnie says on
this day 52 years ago i sat before the
tv non-stop
never thought a billionaire leaving
earth for 11 minutes would be news in
2021
benjamin says david sir on yesterday's
show you talked about how other states
pay for more of the welfare of poorer
states how can i learn more about that
yeah
just do a google search for
biggest takers biggest givers by
state and you will find a list
thanks to elevated disc golf as well as
flaming
fecal leakage and headhunter games
for the twitch subs numbers 13 14
and 15. really appreciate that and uh
still on the table
oh also thanks to jen here for gifting a
subscription on this very special day
also on the table the coupon code up in
the air good uh
up until and through today's flight
let's listen in as we're down to the
last 17 minutes before the scheduled
launch
stay tuned everybody all right we're
going to toss it back to capcom i
understand
that we've got a special message from uh
christina bezos
sister to jeff whoa
whoa
whoa
whoa
okay
for people asking on that note jeff and
mark i have a special message from you
for your
from your sister christina
steve and i are so excited for this
monument okay we don't need that
for people asking what's different about
this launch than the branson launch the
branson launch
was essentially a uh um
a fairy plane which cat which does a
normal take off like an airplane rolling
takeoff on a runway
got up into the air as we say
and then a rocket-powered smaller craft
went from there
and got up into zero gravity it also had
two pilots this mission is different in
that it is a vertical takeoff rocket
that also
lands vertically the capsule on the tip
um is uh everything is automated and
controlled remotely there are no pilots
here so it is
just the four astronauts for lack of a
better term
um is it possible it will blow up
i mean listen anything's possible
obviously i hope i hope that doesn't
happen i hope no one dies here
i do want to say thank you to brent
monger
for signing up with the coupon code up
in the air on my website
sir your wife is up in the air also
thank you to paul
howitt for signing up on my website with
the coupon code up in the air
new members 17 and 18 also thanks to
lethal bee
for the twitch prime sub number 19 and
we will be
gleefully opening up the discord phone
lines after the launch
if we fill the bar to 100
um okay no other super chats there
do i have any other yeah i'll do a
couple voicemails why we break
wait we're in a brief hold let's see
what that's about customer
and soon to be the youngest person to
travel to space at 18. oh i see so we're
in a hole that now is in up to 30
seconds this will delay the launch
slightly it looks like
to go space i guess my first memories of
space
were thunderbirds i was a big fan of
that
watched every single episode there was
that was like the big thing with like
the rockets and everything
oliver is this your first look at the
vehicle yeah it's soaking to go with
this group because wally is like one of
the best pilots ever
and has such an amazing life story of
course jeff is one of the best
businessmen ever and a great visionary
and mark is a firefighter and has such
an amazing track record of his life
i feel have responsibility because i'm
the youngest in space and to get more
people interested in space
and not even just space with science
weeps wow okay so that's all going on
just a couple of
couple voicemails for people uh just to
see we're up to july 6th
at this point in going through the
voicemails
so i've been looking into just like um
trying to make business and stuff with
um some of these people that have um
funds available and it's just like did
she say making sex
um there's like people who can't like
literally take out their money for funds
for
like and do anything with it like
all right and again remember we're just
we're just going through voicemails
david this is raymond elliot i'm
probably your biggest fan
but i did have a question for you
why do you seem to
not enjoy your callers
when they talk to you it seems
to me that you're frustrated that you
have to take the calls
no i'm not frustrated that i have to
take the calls but
sometimes i am frustrated with the
callers you know like for example
when they go on for three minutes before
telling me why they're calling
or you know they're exercising or
operating heavy machinery during the
phone call sometimes that
that is frustrating but the vast
majority of the callers
are uh great hi dave welcome back
i've listened to the video of donald
trump saying that who knows if you have
to pay taxes on a company car
or some uh weisselberg's grandkids
education
uh dave i've admitted to being part of
the lowest
occupation there is uh i'm a used car
salesman dave i've already told you that
okay
every i thought the eggman worked in a
factory i could have sworn he worked in
a factory
a car that i sell has a paper trail it's
bought from auction it's sold by a
dealer taxes get paid in new york state
it's inspected by new york state must
pass inspection every single
nickel of that deal is taxed and looked
over
if i fudge one number by bullcrap
one little thing the irs is the new york
state
motor vehicles is up my butt in a minute
all right so eggman furious i guess
because he's
has there's more oversight on him than
on than on trump
um jonathan mccartney says as a social
democrat how do you address the
fundamental problem of politicians who
won't act against their own financial
interests won't any progress be made
reversible through bribery etc
no you just need to deal with we we can
fix campaign finance i mean there there
are countries that are social
democracies
that don't have the corruption and
cronyism problems that we do
and that i mean you know norway for
example is a country that is seen
that is very very not corrupt there are
like corruption rankings norway is very
not corrupt it's a capitalist country
um so no i don't i don't buy that at all
matt says david do you think this is all
kind of a waste until we find some other
fuel source
more efficient and faster than typical
combustibles that has to be done
i don't think this is a waste hopefully
these types of things
will encourage and foment that
development
are you going to cover the shooting
outside of the nationals baseball game
honestly
there's dozens of shootings every
weekend so i don't know i mean there's
as i said before there's been another
shooting i don't know
i mean it's it's crazy because it's
barely news at this point that's it's
it's
just it's disturbing sir is there
anything biden can do via eo to
decriminalize cannabis i feel like this
is important
i believe that there are things biden
could do via executive order on cannabis
but he doesn't seem willing to do them
or interested in doing them
uh pretty aggressive message from kimmy
which we're not gonna look at right now
if you're just joining us we were
scheduled for a launch
six minutes from now due to an earlier
hold
and then we're currently in a five
minute hold
if the hold were to be released right
now the launch would be pushed back to
909
am and with every passing second of hold
um marked by h in the top right of your
screen
the launch is delayed believed that it
won't be
a very long hold let's see if they're
saying anything about it
well let's hope this doesn't lead to a
cancellation
but we are watching it all really really
closely i
do have some people um that i want to
thank
because we've got some incredible
membership dumps happening right now
they call them dumps
marc-andre rivard just signed up with
the coupon code
up in the air nico young
signing up with a different coupon code
which we won't mention today
also adam zane signing up with the
coupon code
up in the air new members 20 21
and 22 and if you're mad
that bezos is buying his way into space
you can send in your bezos bucks via
a twitch prime subscription like jeff
and boston just did
and a user with the incredibly coarse
username
flaming fecal leakage just did same with
dicey
numbers 23 24 and 25.
let's listen to a couple more voicemails
just going through them in order
why is it that the english are always
getting money for like their duties when
it's like the rest of us need to work
why i mean i'm like trying to do
business with these people but they're
like i have a duty
i'm like i need a job and money and
stuff i don't
yep all right so that's that's
continuing
hi david my question for you has to do
with why do you think
corporations don't support medicare for
all when medicare for all would allow
them to stop paying for their employees
health insurance i can imagine that's
like a huge cost for them
and it would make sense to me if they
would want to be able to pass that
expense off
to the government and to the fact that
they're not really supporting it
seems puzzling to me so i want to offer
you three ideas
that i have for why that might be the
case oh and this goes a full three
minutes itemizing the ideas
yeah that's just it's not a good
voicemail for us typically
um did i see marjorie taylor green got
her twitter account suspended i did
i've received confirmation from the cia
that bezos is returning home to his
alien homeworld with all of our
amazon prime subscriptions david i
wonder if you saw the viral clip of
yours reacting to hassan on live stream
fails yeah we just
we just saw it um we just watched it a
few minutes ago
in fact more voicemails about the
english
these english people literally want to
like take
german money and pretend like they're
giving them
money from their pockets like they want
to like steal money out of germany
and then give it to them as if it's
theirs like they did something
for germans okay and then one more from
the same color
you know what i think happened i think
that germany and england
decided to make peace after the war and
things were going a little bit well for
a while
until the scottish jumped in scotty
started beating [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
face and tearing their [ __ ] dresses
because they can't fit into stuff
wow all right that's probably good i
think i'm good on voicemails at least
for
today the hold has been lifted and we're
now under
14 minutes left until the launch i want
to say thank you to jerry anthony live
as well as virgie verg for the twitch
prime subscriptions numbers
26 and 27 on this incredible day
on which we are sending jeff bezos up
into the air
sir your wife is up in the air moments
away 13 and a half minutes
and um we the whole we had two holds
which
essentially has delayed the launch from
9am eastern
to about 9 12 a.m eastern as of right
now
and then we'll see if any further holds
uh delay things further people saying
uh oh come on guys people are using the
code i know that it's working
we have a special code today up in the
air
and i can assure you that it is working
you just go in you pick the membership
of your choice you hit the sign up
button
coupon code up in the air
turns six dollars into
a dollar 98 an incredible deal okay the
code's working fine you just saw me do
it
no issues whatsoever with the code
um yet by the way it wasn't just
on live stream fails i think that some
of my exchange
last week with stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii
and hassan and the whole thing it was on
the destiny subreddit it was on the
hassan subreddit
the um i think that where i was taking
the most heat
including anti-semitic comments was the
hassan subreddit i think the destiny
subreddit was generally positive about
me
the hassan subreddit was very negative
and then the live stream fails
group was mixed very very mixed
which is fine you know did not every
show is for everybody
not every show is for everybody thanks
to jason kidd
as well as charlie major for the twitch
prime subscriptions numbers 28 and 29.
we are about to go sub 10 minutes
remaining
before the launch everything going as
planned other than a couple of small
holds um oh they're going to the 100
kilometer line
that was my mistake earlier i said 100
miles it's the 100 kilometer line
profile how they're getting up to space
over the karman line and back home down
here to west texas absolutely so
t minus zero is the the time
that we actually gary if you don't mind
standing by i understand that we are uh
ready for our go no-go poll whoa
big pole
so it looks like it's happening
okay it's happening it's happening and
people are getting very very worked up
i want to say thank you to jen here for
gifting two more subs via twitch also
thanks to gcf for the twitch prime
appreciate that numbers 30 31 and 32.
um to have that kind of money and not
even try to become batman is more than
disappointing
very very insightful comment by d parks
i also want to say thank you to hans
badal
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code up in the air
number 33 putting us 33 percent of the
way
to um our goal at which point we will
open the phone lines today
we are going under 10 minutes with a go
for launch
just announced just announced getting
that last
bit of time before this incredible
launch
thanks to chronically steph appreciate
the twitch prime
subscription um expect it to be
an 11 minute flight 11 minute flight if
you're just joining us
jeff bezos mark bezos
wally funk and an 18 year old kid whose
name is just
just on the tip of my tongue but his
name i'm forgetting have already
uh been loaded into the capsule
and we are nine and a half minutes from
lunch oliver
oliver yes i want to say thanks to mike
oftdoll for signing up with the coupon
code up in the air
also want to say thank you to oh it
looks like hans either deliberately or
not
got two memberships using the code up in
the air
we'll celebrate it anyway sir your wife
is up in the air
uh putting us at 36. also thanks to
glock
for the twitch prime sub getting us to
37 yes people wondering if you'll have
to be here for hours it is only expected
to be
an 11 minute flight 11 minute flight
and then as you can see here the capsule
will then
come back down with a uh so so there's
basically two things
this is a vertical takeoff craft the new
shepherd
the entire thing will take off the
capsule separates
and comes back down with a parachute
whereas the rocket
then has a vertical landing similar to
the spacex technology
that is the plan in their seats they'll
be thrusters that will
stabilize the capsule just to prevent it
from rocking too much and then
parachutes will deploy about
10 000 feet above the ground first drugs
will fire and those will extract the
mains
and then finally a landing will occur on
a cushion of air
which will fire um just about six feet
off the ground
what's this is this guy from like uh
upstate new york or something i'm
hearing that
fire instead of fire i don't know who
this guy is but that's what i'm picking
up on
goes everywhere and so when we have that
air cushion that fires they really kicks
up the dust
but again they're coming in at just
about one or two miles an hour it's a
really nice
soft landing and uh again gary we
confirmed we are
go for launch for first human flight on
new shepard
oh my goodness seven minutes you've been
waiting for this day
i can tell people they're getting
excited they're dumping in memberships
left and right
brad stipak signing up with the coupon
code up in the air
on my website cheryl hudson signing up
with the coupon code up in the air
sum telukhtar signing up with the coupon
code
up in the air numbers 38 39
and 40. this will go to 100 kilometers
above sea level it will be an 11 minute
flight expected to be
david sir love this trump sound bites on
the show hilarious idea keep using them
what's your strategy to get vaccination
rates up or are we just doomed
i have i'm going to do a segment on
today's show actually about how fox news
i think probably because of legal
problems
is all of a sudden saying hey vaccines
are a great idea
can you give your two cents on the very
anti-space exploration
rhetoric shared by many and belief that
the rich are trying to escape climate
change through space so i addressed that
earlier and on a recent bonus show
but basically i i am not hugely uh
um uh compelled by those arguments
can i get a membership for a friend if
so how yes you go to the website
join pacman.com make sure you're logged
out of your account
then just make a new membership and put
in your friend's name and email as the
person signing up
but you pay for it that's the way to do
it
i also want to say thanks to margaret
seeger margaret
signing up with the coupon code up in
the air on my website
it's only an 11 minute flight guys take
advantage of it before it disappears
forever
now down to the sub six minute mark
sub six minute mark um
you know the other thing about
billionaires escaping climate change
i don't believe that this is going to
reap rewards
i don't think there's going to be any
place for jeff bezos to go to to escape
climate change during his lifetime so i
actually don't think that that's really
the motivation here
it could be for the glory it could be
because you know maybe he wants to be
seen
a thousand years from now when humans
have found another place
to live to escape climate change as the
guy who did it a sort of jesus-like
figure
um for lack of a better term although
you know i mean why
i don't even know why i'm saying that
jesus is not a figure that's meaningful
to me
but anyway um so i think it's more
vanity
it's more yeah i don't think it's
because bezos thinks he's gonna find
himself a new place to live
um there is a user here
who is being really annoying uh
yeah we're gonna ban them yeah there we
go
david what sorts of tax benefits can mr
bezos look forward to once he leaves the
atmosphere
it's hard to tax people that are up in
the air sir your wife is up in the air
i want to say thank you to hampus
carlson
for signing up on my website and looks
like hampus
yeah hampus carlson marianne
lake knit i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
and james buchanan signing up with the
coupon code up in the air numbers 42 43
and 44. i very much appreciate that
we are now under five minutes five
minutes
before the launch let's listen in to see
what's being discussed
some last minute checks on the vehicle
at t-minus
two minutes is when the vehicle we throw
the show over to her
it's it's all on her it's an autonomous
vehicle but gary do you want to talk to
us about
what are some of those last you know
last minute checks that the the vehicle
is going through
and that we're going to see especially
on our screen right right so as you
mentioned the last two minutes
are auto sequence and that is executed
entirely by the vehicle itself
through an automated checklist you'll
see a couple of things
there will be things that you don't see
such as sensor checks
pressure checks on the tanks
radio checks all hundreds and hundreds
of different checks will be stepped
through in this checklist but what you
will see is a hydraulic system spooling
up
which will wiggle the engine gimbal as
well as the outfins
wow those they're they're not only
wiggling those surfaces but they're
making sure that there's no stickers the
gimbal is actually a pretty
sophisticated
piece of equipment um down to the last
three minutes after two holds that
delayed the launch from 9 a.m
eastern to about 9 12 9 13
it is now a go as far as we know jeff
bezos mark bezos
wally funk and an 18 year old named
oliver
will be going up to the 100
kilometer uh mark
i want to say thank you to aaron kissel
for signing up with the coupon code
up in the air also dan cardinal taking
advantage of today's coupon code numbers
45 and 46.
when we get to the two-minute mark we
will take the live audio from blue
origin
um alejandro ruiz sends the hashtag sos
cuba yes
i've done a number of segments about
cuba
wendy says as a cuban-american your take
on the gusano thing has been a breath of
fresh air non-hispanos are throwing that
word around while my people
die yeah not a term i use
disproportionately
uh used uh for for white
latin americans and just just you know
let's talk about policy guys let's talk
about policy
all right here we go the bridge
we have retraction troy moser signing up
oh my god
is on the right we are about to go to
space everybody
[Applause]
here we go
90 seconds now
alright when that engine gimbal check
occurs and that engine swings they
should actually be able to feel it
uh in the cabin because it'll sway the
stack back
70 seconds checks yes this is live guys
come on you think i'm gonna do this on a
repeat
one minute there you see the
engine gimbal check just peeking out at
the base of the rocket
wow
[Music]
all right here we go everybody thousands
of people contributed
years to this historic moment ladies and
gentlemen
it's time for blue origin's first human
flight godspeed
first crew of new shepard let's light
this candle
t-minus 16 guidance internal
t-minus t-10 we're on internal guidance
seven six five four
command engine start two one
whoa
[Music]
human crew go jeff go
marco wally go oliver you are going to
space
30 seconds in
oh my goodness listen to the roar of the
be3 engine we are just about to pass
through max q
maximum dynamic pressure that was when
the stresses on the vehicle are at their
maximum
max cube max q is confirmed
beautiful burn on that be3 engine
liquid hydrogen and
liquid oxygen as the propellant it's a
nice
not just clean in terms of uh
beautifully performing but
what comes out of it it's steam right
wow to see to see the
the the glow of the of the engine
underneath the rocket just under our
shoulders
and to know that we've got a crew that
is going to space
it it just feels different doesn't it
gary
it is totally different
all right you can follow along of course
the speedometer in the bottom left
the altimeter in the uh middle
approaching mach 2.
[Music]
so far appears to be a nominal flight
two minutes in
all right coming up here on mikko main
engine cut off that will be followed
shortly
by separation and at that point after
separation we're gonna uh
let the astronauts unbuckle and take in
the freedoms of zero g
there is miko main engine cutoff wow
a beautiful shot down the new shepard
rocket
look at that view
unreal into zero g now
remember the branson craft reached 279
thousand feet
they're already almost there and going
well beyond that
we will soon be able to confirm whether
or not the earth is flat
imminently and here we are you can start
to see
stand by you're going to see the
separation of the capsule
from the booster itself
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint
of water
[Applause]
oh
and there we go our astronauts have
passed the carmen line at about 328
000 feet continuing their ascent wow
you see the two vehicles there
when the speed hits zero you know that
they've hit apogee they're
maximum altitude and you hear their
happen
quite an experience
okay so this should be about the halfway
point here yeah
expect it to be about 11 minutes
they are now descending
now accelerating back down
oh
okay
that's wally funk pointing out it's dark
up here
everybody
[Music]
wally
and slowing down
[Music]
[Applause]
copy
so there is the rocket thank you again
everybody for joining us live for our
first even flight on new shepard so far
a nominal flight our booster is about to
return
to its landing pad wow there we see
engine relies
wow
down to five miles an hour
wow and has touched down the booster is
back
welcome back new shepard
a beautiful rocket that provided a
beautiful flight to space
wow first
up your booster has landed guys it's not
even centered on this
i mean come on you couldn't even put it
in the middle of the circle give me a
break guys
here is the capsule capsule still at 16
000 feet expecting the parachute
momentarily
our four crew members on board you have
a
very happy crew up here i want you to
know
oh yeah i see blue
[Music]
expecting there it is the first three
parachutes
stand by maine
expecting the main parachute momentarily
slowed down to about 100.
there it is here comes the crew capsule
back from space the drogues deployed
here the mains out reefing and coming to
down to 20 miles an hour
15 miles an hour it went over mach 3
and now they're coming floating back
down at just about
15 or 16 miles an hour about to join us
home
wow back here in west texas after having
gone
over the carbon line the internationally
recognized line of space
the world's newest astronauts gary how
are you holding up friend
i'm delightful i am speechless united
states
wow and those big beautiful windows
they've just got about a minute and a
half of
floating before uh the activation of the
skirt jet
to for a for a soft touchdown
at this point um there are the last
thousand feet that are detecting how
high they are above the ground
multiple sensors and just six feet above
the ground that that cushion of air will
will puff and they will have a soft
touchdown almost like
just sitting in a chair 600 feet
expected to be right around 11 minutes
very close to that exactly
still 16 miles per hour down to the last
300 feet
looks like a drone there wow
and here it is 20 feet
and they are down touchdown 10 minutes
20 seconds
new shepard's first human crew
what congratulations sir you just won
the elections to all of
all of you the rocket is back and the
capsule is back
on this capsule and it works so great
for everybody who made this spot
thank you blue patrol oliver thank you
so much for everyone there was amazing
it was
amazing wow copy first step you have a
very
happy capcom here as well let's do a
status check
astronaut oliver
[Music]
i think you could hear wally funk on
oliver's mic there copy
after netdemo
astronaut demo i am unbelievably good
copy
[Music]
copy everyone go ahead and remain in
your seats crewmember 7 is on their way
shortly you will hear the capsule
off-gassing
we're going to see some pretty serious
off-gassing momentarily
wow
i do want to say thanks to cece barton
for signing up with the code up in the
air
your apogee was 351
210 feet
[Applause]
[Music]
so the capsule is back
[Music]
[Applause]
we're now waiting for uh support
vehicles to get to the capsule
the capsule will be off-gassing
um supposedly amazon prime will deliver
to the capsule in just about 20 minutes
i was surprised at how easy zero g was
yeah yeah it felt it felt very like
remarkably natural
it's like swimming yeah yeah it's not it
is it's
weird
well what a day you can see our four
the the world's new newest minted
astronauts
are there on board discussing their
incredible flight of a lifetime
up to space and back wow um
our team is now preparing uh landing
safety operations
oh yeah so here are the support vehicles
at the bottom of the screen
well minutes ago has left the barn there
to go
uh uh uh open the hatch you can see them
there they're arriving at the capsule
in the riviens you can actually also see
that the parachutes
fell very close to the capsule it means
that there's not much wind out there is
a beautiful beautiful day
not too shabby gary what do you think no
it was picture perfect
and and it sounds like it landed pretty
much exactly where we predicted that's
how they can get to it so quickly
wow moving even before it landed based
on
on the prediction of landing um we use
weather balloons that we launched
throughout the morning and that that
gives us a very good idea of where it
will land which are within a thousand
feet
uh what you're seeing that they're doing
right now is is kevin's program crew
member seven is just making sure
everybody is okay and gives them a
thumbs up
um they're also grounding the vehicle
when you go into space
you could accumulate pretty significant
electric charge
that's actually why we prefer that the
astronauts not get
out themselves so that we can ground the
vehicle of static charge which can be
quite strong
excellent and i think there that kevin
sprogue our crewmember 7 has given the
given the thumbs up uh for all of our
our
uh our astronauts that are on board
there again jeff bezos mark bezos
wally funk and oliver damon
what an incredible day you heard them on
the audio best day
ever i mean this is this i feel like
this is our best day ever and we didn't
even get to go up to space
i mean what a day again congratulations
and of course the friends and family of
these
uh incredible astronauts they're just
about the exit
the capsule here let's wait for that
imagine if they open it and bernie comes
out and they say how was
it yeah good okay
felix is up here
they have all the important things
including a huge boom mic
you're the main person
[Music]
you're just moving the one of the main
parachute lines to make sure it doesn't
snag the hatch when it opens
thanks infectious for the twitch prime
sub appreciate that
[Music]
remember you can use the coupon code up
in the air today
because of this launch to get a
membership on my website a whole bunch
of people have
and it is it's quite the code
[Music]
no i got this stuff
no it's not open oh my god
[Music]
confirm okay so you can go live
they're about i guess to open the hatch
gary the architect of new shepard
congratulations to you man
congratulations give me a hug this
is just oh
what what a day
again thank you everybody for joining us
live for our first
human flight of new shepard our four
astronauts
went to space and back topping over 350
000 feet well over 100 kilometers
they've come back down safely we're just
waiting here for egress
our crew is going to get out of the
capsule and meet their families back
here
on the ground of course their families
that have provided so much support since
they were little kids
and dreamt of this to this day and this
moment
let me know whatever
family are we ready
[Applause]
there's wally funk a crowd favorite
[Applause]
[Music]
we are able to do mercy bands if people
need them congratulations
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
what a day again here as successful
launch and landing of the new shepard
rocket and crew capsule with
our first human flight crew there
jeff bezos mark bezos oliver damon
and wally funk
and their families there giving big hugs
all around
what a moment so much emotion
from all of them the the elation did you
see wally
did you see wally when she came out you
know this
i told you she was just she was probably
gonna do a summer you know
cartwheel as she came out of that
capsule what an incredible incredible
day
let's just capture a couple more moments
of this again
space flight so much engineering so much
objective hard engineering technical
thought that goes into it but when you
put people on
board there's such an incredible
emotional component to this
the the the time the effort the blood
sweat and tears
you know this better than anybody else
again congratulations gary thank you
ariane
and congratulations to the entire blue
argent team
this might have looked easy today it was
anything but easy
to design a vehicle like this that is so
safe
that anybody can get on board from wally
funk
who today became the world's
oldest astronaut so presumably this is
the first in a series of launches and i
think that there will be if any of you
are looking to buy a seat on an upcoming
one of these i do think that there will
be opportunities to do that
um if you're not sure you know if you
have too much super chat money you're
not sure what to do with it it's
conceivable you could buy a seat on one
of these upcoming and you could become
an astronaut
some people in the chat sort of angry
with the term astronaut being applied to
these individuals
uh i i will leave it to others to decide
about that
apparently they do take doji coin i
can't wait to hear their impressions of
the you know the view from up there and
in fact i hear in just a moment we uh we
hope to be getting a couple of
impressions from
our astronauts we'll stand by for that
there
you see uh yeah the friends the family
you see our ceo
bob smith there uh you see uh a couple
of our other executives of course this
crew
safety team and it's champagne time
everybody
[Applause]
now where i believe they're in is it
texas so it's an hour it's 8 30 in the
morning there where they are
is that right exactly the only proper
way to end a space flight
with a champagne shower and man
that is let me just tell you that is the
beginning of the celebrations there is a
lot more to come
we are again not just the crew and the
families but everybody at blue origin
who has made the historic day possible
and historic day
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there's a big hug from jeff to wally
funk
could we possibly get a camera in
tighter there's it looks like there's
four or five cameras down there
to go to space in the 60s she had to
wait to the 2020s but man it was worth
the wait
there you see the bezos brothers hugging
it out
oliver damon you saw him earlier giving
his father a big hug
what a moment she saw the first hug when
jeff came out of the capsule
to his mother jackie followed by his
father
mike i mean
again what what a day we really learned
guys
it takes a special sort of courage to be
a billionaire
you contributed to today as well i know
you are all hugging it out
back in kent washington at our
headquarters near seattle
sending you guys a lot of love from down
here in west texas
what a moment
[Laughter]
i imagine look at this girl
i mean granted you know gary we weren't
in the capsule
but my favorite part was hearing you
know the hooting and hollering
and the laughing you know jeff is known
for his big boisterous laugh
i mean he is uh he's having the moment
of a lifetime here and you can only
imagine as they were floating around
up there you saw them say gosh look at
look at the view i do want to say thank
you to alice maravius
who said all i see here is the reason
i don't have affordable health care
number 52 today
also want to say thanks to daniel
meisner who just signed up with the
coupon code
up in the air on my website and his new
member number 53.
work backwards to make the design and
then
and then build and then build forwards
when you sat there 17 years ago
with this with the very small team at
the time
at blue is this what you would imagine
it's certainly what we hoped for but
with the size of the team when i
joined blue origin there were only 20 of
us in a warehouse
and it would have taken a huge leap of
faith to think that we could have gotten
to this point but we have
just just incredible uh you know
i've been here seven years we were at
300 so man you got me beat by
by a lot there but you know i can
remember when we
when when i joined the team and we were
talking about
this the moment the day that we were
gonna fly
people you know you talk about it by the
way
welcome to all the new uh people on
twitch that just stumbled upon this and
have no idea who i am in the bottom
right of your screen
still love to see you i'm glad people
are following and and hope you'll be
back for subsequent streams
uh as a very different completely
different sort of event
donald trump does have a rally on
saturday and i don't know that it will
be the engineering
or or technical um uh
demonstration that today was
but uh i will be streaming trump's rally
on saturday
big massive dumps yeah so that'll be
something sort of to look forward to but
welcome to all the new people on twitch
who are here and have no idea who i am
still glad you're here
and i think based on uh based on what we
see there i i think
you know job well done sir job well done
and not only did we do it today we can
do it again
and again and again precisely
absolutely love it that was amazing
everybody i want to thank you all for
joining us from around the world
for today's blue origin historic first
human flight
it's been a moment for the ages and
guess what
we're just getting started wow two more
flights this year
and several more in the coming years i
want you to join us a little bit later
today we're going to have a live press
conference on our website
you're going to get to hear the all
right everybody that is it i really
appreciate you being here
make sure you're subscribed on youtube
and also following on twitch so you'll
be notified of subsequent streams the
next stream won't be another one of
these launches
um it'll be a political event maybe a
gensake
uh press conference over the next couple
days
and then saturday night for the trump
rally so we are going to see everybody
really really soon
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive
host an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's amazing they go along with
homosexuality hold on but holy whoa whoa
jesse well we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot hang on we
would everything that's
raw abortion they think and act just
like a woman obeying a male dog
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
[Music]
[Music]
he david patman he is
david patman he is a beta male 1
he gave it pacman he is
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're actually like
an idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right goodbye
they are weak people and why having
people on it doesn't even